go okay so i'm going to talk about immunoconstitution and um why i think that's
important these are my disclosures and uh uh primarily you know the the reason i'm focusing
on this is you know everybody is very much aware of the acute um immune cell mediated toxicities
you know i can's was described in crs etc and a new grading system developed but after this first
month or so people kind of lose track of what's going on so our 10-year experience follow-up will
be published shortly probably in the next month or so and it's very enlightening to have followed
these patients for a decade and i can share some of of this with you but i want to really get some
concepts and i'm really open to ideas so there is immune deficiency that happens as a consequence
of immunoconstitutions and immunoconstitutions and immunoconstitutions and immunoconstitutions
of lymphodepletion duh you know of course but we hope that that that's repaired or recovers because
if it doesn't you're stuck with a patient that is you know has profound immune deficiency
indefinitely and and what what uh there are patients that are indefinitely immune suppressed
after CAR-T and how do we predict you know who that's going to be how do we mitigate that well
there's certain things we can't change we can't change our age yet
okay and so that's pre-existing it's a patient characteristic they come in that way also the
things that oncologists use to treat lymphoma really kill normal lymphocytes pretty well too
so they're often immunosuppressed related to their therapies and lymphoma itself you know
those malignant cells have ligands that poison the immune system and result in immunosuppression
so these are things you can't control patient comes to you with them but we want to see if this
this repairs itself with correction in the malignancy and over time and how the CAR-T health
various aspects of CAR-T therapy uh impact on that um one thing we'll talk about is lymphodepletion
um i didn't know having had the benefit of starting this in in 2012 i didn't know that you had to use
cytoxifluid irb nobody told me that was mandatory of course all the sponsors uh put it in the package
insert and that was the primary thing to do but you know sometimes there's a benefit to being not so
smart but you know there's a benefit to being not so smart but you know sometimes there's a benefit
um i'll show you some data uh also uh i'm a living example of that by the way um and also the CAR-T
product itself is important in in the recovery after this okay so if you look at this uh drawing
that i'm so proud of up in the left you see the patient well you can't control his his lymphocyte
count that's a consequence of the disease his past therapies can't control the age can't control the
disease kinetics um or the past chemotherapeutics um you can't control the age can't control the
therapies uh all those things impact on what's been called t-cell fitness how do you define t-cell
fitness well uh it's a t-cell that not only can uh perform its function in in indeed if you're a cdh
cell cytotoxicity but replicates itself it's got stemness self-renewal and uh maintains its function
it's not just there one shot and gone um now the in vitro processing manufacturing also affects
believe it or not immune reconstitution and i'm going to show you some of that in just a moment
some of the data on that and uh of course lymphodepletion has an impact and like i said
i'm pretty glad i didn't know what was mandatory i'm going backwards i think all right so we look
there's all kinds of cells there's b cells monocytes nk cell t cells in that pool we pull
out the t cells on our cd3 you know c28 beads and you know you're getting a mix of cells what you
need to know shown in the upper right is these cells are various stage of differentiation the
ones that are close
have more self replication the naive and memory phenotypes are to the left with progressive
differentiation they no longer replace themselves they can have a terminal effect and these are the
terminal effector cells we have a mix of these cells and that's determined by the patient's
characteristics when they come in and we can look at these cells and that impacts the outcome and
immune recovery once we pull out these t cells you know what we've noticed is actually responses
are seen across a huge dose range you know you do have to give some cells by the way
and we came up with a 0.6 to 6 times 10 to the 8th range for a t cell because this is a broad range
you know so really it was limited by manufacturing we almost never didn't give a product um and uh
and there are a significant number of non-transduced t cells in the product and this impacts immune
reconstitution and it's something we don't pay much attention to pure is not always better um now joe fry
had a pen i always have to show this he was the first one to show the t cell fitness or phenotype
memory characteristics and um um you know impacts outcome in clo group of patients everybody has
shown this in every single disease now and i'm always at lectures hearing it again and again
and you know that was in the t cell fitness in the aphoresis product meaning the patient cells
and he took this the products that were made from these patients and looked at a genomic level
at the signatures for um early
memory or stemness and and terminal differentiation and sure enough the ones that did well had the
young fit uh reproducing cells and the uh terminal uh the differentiated cell patients didn't do as
well okay so i convinced you t cell fitness is important what about age age this is really
interesting data and shows you that guess what age is hard on the immune system and if you look
uh primarily at the cdh what you'll see is the i guess that's a brownish color that seems to
expand with age and that they're the uh terminally differentiated effector cells and the the
the naive t cells both c4 and cd8 are shown in the light gray and um and you can see the proportion
of differentiated cells increases and in naive or inexperienced cells decreases with age i guess we
old cells are more experienced but that's not always a good thing okay um looking on
the right i think this is pretty interesting if you look the age groups so just look at the the
red is old that's greater than 64 by the way and young is less than 40 that's the dark and what you
see is this the red uh dot plot or scatter plot gets progressively shorter you know uh as you look
at the old patients versus the young patients so the the dark blue or black is much higher than the
red when you look at the treatment naive cells and then moving to the the um differentiated
cells to the right you'll see they decrease so the the dark blue or black is much higher than the
old age is important we lose uh some t cell fitness um this and now disease characteristics
okay this comes from chop next door to where i work um these data and patients come in with uh
and these are these data are just from 15 pediatric lymphoma patients and you can see
that they come in i'm sure the normal values on the right because most people don't know the normal
values off the top of their head for these subsets um but they they come in with their cancer before
they're even treated and they're immunodeficient what you can see if you look at the color coding
you know the um the terminal the differentiated cells on the left are the dark black portion of
the bar and the naive and less differentiated of the colorful uh bars and as you move uh through
cycles of chemotherapy these cells you lose the naive and uh memory phenotypes that are
proliferative potential you end up with more terminally differentiated cells with each cycle
of chemotherapy and when you take those patients
and try to expand the cells in vitro there's less expansion after each cycle of chemotherapy so they
even lose the ability to make uh CAR-T cells we all know these three products and we we love them
but guess what they are a little bit different yeah the efficacy is all about the same toxicities
are a bit different i'm going to show you i think there are some differences that relate to
manufacturing that have bear on immunoconstitution um these are the lympho depleting regimens that
um were somehow arrived at oh i know the story in
one case but in any event um uh i want to show you before the days where we knew what to do
what i did okay and these are the data if you look at the large b cell lymphoma and the follicular
lymphoma patients just you can look at toxins but look at cr and uh rate and uh cr duration
um in the pink okay so the trial we did which is a small pilot trial you know uh you could see
our best response and response duration was identical to the multi-center
international juliet trial which was the same product that was licensed from penn so we were
able to export that into 17 different countries or something and and get the same exact results
but i'll show you why i'm showing this in a second flick your lymphoma the same exact thing these are
the results from penn in our small cohort and then this multi-center international trial uh you could
see exactly the same results so when things repeat themselves in science that's considered to be a a
good thing
um okay look at what we did for lymphodepletion in the penn cohort and look at what the studies did
totally different so do you need psy flu i got exactly the same results efficaciously and
toxicity wise and nobody with large cell lymphoma got psy flu i didn't know you had to give it okay
and guess what i don't think you do all right and we will have a study that will be opening this
year ongoing we're going to actually study for the first time the necessity in lymphoma patients
of lymphodepletion and they won't get the same results but they're going to get the same results
they'll get any and they'll cross over to it if they need it and we're going to have a lot of
interesting correlates with that so this has bothered me that you know you get a label and
then everybody's if you can't give you flute arabian i can't treat you not the case okay and
uh same thing with follicular look at the range radiation and cytotoxin versus like same same
outcome okay uh this was a surprise that actually if you go into remission and this relates to
disease two-thirds of the patients in cr at a year uh were recovering their b cells they'd recovered
them polytypic b cells and uh within two years three-quarters of these patients had b cell
uh recovery a quarter of them didn't and i'll show you the next slide about two-thirds of them were
actually reviewing recovering immunoglobulins i'm proud of these reverse waterfall flats plots that
i made to show immunoglobulin changes that's why i'm showing you this uh in any event the the blue
and the green are the um um the latest time points 24 and 30 months and you can see they have that
they increase from the baseline anyway these slides are available you'll have time to look at
them if you care all of our patients had recovered their t cells by the end of the year all of our
patients in remission that is okay that ain't the case with this commercial products but again
these patients were treated differently i didn't do what you're supposed to do but i got the same
results okay um uh now there was a great study which i all which i kind of knew from my practice
but i've used all the commercial products but uh dr luan from memorial put together a multi-center
database where they looked at axi cells he's to sell and lisa sell the three commercial lymphoma
products that we love we don't love brexit cell or ticardus as much but in any event um these
these three he compared in lymphoma patients median follow-up was about two years and he looked at
overall survival to europe that wasn't the point of the study really um they all worked you can't
patient characteristics were slightly different so you know efficacy stuff is limited but anyway
good number of patients and what you want to see here is the tisa cell patients that made the cells
the way we did which had a lot of non-transduced cells contaminating the product not as purified
as the c4 cdh you can see here the c4s uh and and c3 total c3 c4s and h recovered
significantly quicker and more completely than the other two products and again um it relates to
processing i think for and lymphodepletion liver depletion is a lot lighter in the tisa cell group
and it's the effector memory ones the ones you want they're enriched and if you look nk cell
was the same but interestingly those that had in case of recovery fared better survival there was
a trend towards better survival by cd4 account but this is two years follow-up i'm going to tell you
a follow-up now and those that don't get c4 spec have some bad things happen to them that relate
to you know infections and neoplastic events so what about aloe car i want somebody to explain
this to me these patients come in without t cells often and they go get this product so use two ways
to not reject an aloe car you can either engineer them which everyone does to to prevent rejection
but you can also intensify lymphodepletion to prevent the host versus graft effect and look at
this they gave boatloads in the um this is the caribou study 60 megs per kg per day for two days
cytoxin and ferritin for five days this looks like terrible doesn't it well look at the recovery at
at a month yeah they would be so depleted but t and nk is recovered in about three weeks after
this so i if somebody can put this together with the other stuff that i showed i love the hypothesis
anyway i just want to remind everybody philadelphia exists it's not whistler you can't ski there but uh
we we now pull its cell
this um silicon valley since everybody's obsessed with self-rpa thanks for sharing with me overtime